earlier this year we launched a preview
of Android KTX a set of extensions to
the android framework aimed at making
your development with cotton more clear
pleasant and idiomatic since then we had
several releases including contributions
from the community we changed the name
to core KTX and now we're launching the
1.0 alpha version as part of jetpack our
set of libraries aimed at accelerating
android development the core KTX library
contains extensions to the features and
functionality of the framework but we
didn't forget about other Android
jetpack libraries old or new classes
from Android acts like fragment manager
collections live data reactive streams
and the new navigation component have
associated KTX artifacts leveraging the
features of the language such as
extension functions and properties
lambdas named and default parameters now
let's check out some examples without
KTX performing a fragment transaction
requires starting a transaction
triggering an action like adding or
replacing a fragment and then designing
on one of the four commit methods based
on whether the commit should be
scheduled or call synchronously allowing
state loss or not fragment KTX
adds the transaction extension function
to the fragment manager class removing
all the begin transaction and commits
boilerplate as well as providing default
values for sync and state loss that you
can easily over right to avoid
forgetting to call show when is flowing
a toast and to simplify the code use the
context extension function from core KTX
we're here with the spans api we added
extensions to domain classes span
strings Panama string and span of all
string pillar to make the API easier to
use and more idiomatic so for example
creating a span of all from a string
making the text bold and only a word
read can be easily done like this make
your menu items eat trouble perform
actions on each item in the menu check
whether a specific item is or not there
or remove items easily using the Android
X support SQLite database when
implementing database transactions you
need quite a lot of boilerplate
with the SQLite KTX you can focus on
matters the operations that you want to
make in the database and then just let
the transaction method handle the rest
the new navigation component from
Android chef pack already offers a
domain-specific language for working
with it so for example to set up in code
a navigation graph with a search action
that saves it from hitting the back
button ten times to get through all the
past results and has animations for
entering and exiting he would write
something like this you would create a
graph based on the star destination ID
on action for search with a destination
ID and navigation options in the
navigation options were setting the
search fragment to be launched as single
top with an enter and an exit animation
so core fragment navigation and others
all of these are the first steps towards
a cleaner simpler and more idiomatic
Android development medical team and we
won't be stopping here
follow us on github YouTube and Twitter
for more news